what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and today I thought we would do another
origin of Howard's video since a lot of
you guys were really asking about
Darkseid's pops yuga khan and since
we've been covering some of the stuff
from like DC's Fourth World lately I
figured now is as good a time as any to
go over Yuga Khan's origin and powers
now as for its comic book origin in the
post-crisis landscape which is to say
after 1985 when DC rebooted yuga Khan
was reintroduced to DC Comics by Mark
Evanier and Paris Collins and made his
debut in New Gods vol 3
issue number 17 in June of 1990 little
bit of history here for those of you
guys who are new to comic books there is
something in DC called the fourth world
and the way this worked was that in like
1971 I think it was Marvel artist Jack
Kirby basically one half of the dynamic
duo they basically introduced characters
in Marvel like Thor and you know Iron
Man and the return of Captain America so
on and so forth Jack Kirby left Marvel
because he was getting mad that Marvel
was basically giving all the credit to
Stan Lee and they weren't giving any to
him the result is that he went over to
DC Comics and created something called
the fourth world and the fourth world
was basically going to be this totally
isolated universe that was huge and
drawn-out and massively expansive the
problem is that DC treated him like crap
too so he left and went back to Marvel
and DC basically had a half-finished
project and so what they did is they
took everything Jack Kirby had done with
the fourth world and they just rolled it
over into DC Comics into all the
superhero stories that's why you have
like Darkseid as a main villain of
Superman of the Justice League or
something along those lines
that was all stuff that Jack Kirby made
and DC threw into their main superhero
line of stories now in 1985 when DC
rebooted they basically took what little
was not tied into the larger DC Universe
from the Fourth World and fully rolled
it all in at least whatever it was they
decided to keep now since then since his
basically second appearance more or less
in 1990 Yuga Khan has only made a
handful of appearances most of which
occurred in the issues immediately
following his first appearance so we
don't know a great deal about his
backstory but what we do know is that
you kakan is one of the new gods which
is a race of extremely powerful
human-like beings that exists outside of
space and time and a realm known as the
fourth world at least that was the
original intention after crisis on
Infinite Earths because the multiverse
was eliminated he only had one universe
and so what DC did in order to reconcile
the existence of
the new gods who were traditionally
outside of a multiverse they basically
said they were in the universe of BC
they were just walled off from
everything else it was just kind of a
galaxy out there somewhere and it we
just walled off from everything in
existence but the idea here is that
within the fourth world there exists two
main planets New Genesis which is
basically designed to be heaven in a lot
of different ways and apocalypse which
is designed to be the other place we
can't say the actual word because of
YouTube D monetization so both of these
planets basically came into existence
following the destruction of a previous
planet called Berggren which was
basically split into two separate
planets following his destruction and
the death of the old gods but we also
know that you kakan was the first ruler
of apocalypse now desperate to acquire
more power so that he could become the
most powerful entity in the universe
Yuga Khan became obsessed with solving
the mystery of something known as the
source the source within DC Comics is
basically the impetus for everything
that exists within the universe and is
the source of limitless energy which
every living thing within the universe
comes from so there's different theories
out there in terms of what the source is
and I don't believe has ever been
explicitly fleshed out it's just sort of
this evening Matic somewhat obscure
thing that exists out there that you
only really hear about in the New Gods
comics but despite having been warned
that acquiring knowledge of the source
would result in his destruction by the
ruler of New Genesis highfather yuga
khan tracked the source to the
Promethean galaxy one of the most remote
places in the universe that borders the
source wall a barrier that separates the
source from everything in existence now
while yuga khan is successful in finding
the source what ends up happening is
that he becomes imprisoned inside the
source wall for several thousand years
now during this time and back on
apocalypse Yuga Khan's wife Hera assumed
power in his absence but lost her life
due to a plot put in motion by her son
you SAS UQ's ass as we know would
eventually go on to become Darkseid once
he assumed the mantle of control of
apocalypse now eventually Yuga Caan
manages to free himself from the source
walk and almost immediately consume the
planet Delos after destroying its
protective force field so that he could
absorb its energy he then destroys a
probe station owned by the thanagarians
the alien race that Hawkman and Hawk
woman belong to and feeds on another
planet to bolster his own strength
before returning to apocalypse to
reclaim his throne which he's able to do
by imprisoning Darkseid and
disintegrating desaad now during his
second stint as ruler of epochal
yuga khan proves to be an even more
brutal dictator than darkside himself
had ever been however he does not stick
around long as he once again tries to
set off and enter the source and then
he's once again imprisoned as a result
so definitely a powerful guy not the
sharpest tool in the shed
Yoga Khan is kind of an idiot so now
that we've covered his origin we can get
into unit Khan's powers which are really
pretty immense and he's probably one of
the most powerful of all the new gods
and certainly one of the only beings
that has been able to instill fear in
Darkseid so because he belongs to the
race of new gods he has all the powers
common to the new gods like immortality
invulnerability to blunt force attacks
super strength stamina speed reflexes
all that kind of good stuff but in
addition to all of that you go Khan is
able to employ a litany of additional
powers that make him one of the most
powerful beings in the DC Universe as an
example yuga Khan can create constructs
of pure energy and we see this happen
when he attacks the thanagarian probes
station which leads to him having a
showdown with the Kryptonian mano which
if he watched the Supergirl TV show on
CW then you probably know who Mon L is
but he's basically a member of an alien
race called the Dax amides that was on a
team called the Legion of super-heroes
and is pretty much the exact same powers
of Superman except for his weakness to
kryptonite because kind of use
Kryptonian kind of not the reason why I
say that is because within DC Comics the
daksa mites are basically Kryptonians
who left Krypton and settled on a planet
called dachshund they don't really have
a weakness to kryptonite per se instead
for the most part their weakness is led
now during his battle with mono Yuga
Khan is able to create a net out of pure
energy that's strong enough to trap mono
who as we said possesses a level of
strength roughly equivalent to Superman
now Yuga Khan is also able to absorb the
energy of other living beings as well as
planets as he did after free himself
from the source wall now doing this
allows you to Khan to become even more
powerful than he already is he also
possesses some mental abilities like
telekinesis and telepathy and the
ability to create illusions that can be
seen by others as he did when he
reminded desaad of the murder of hydra
right before he disintegrated him now
prior to this though music on
demonstrates another one of the
ridiculous powers he possesses the
ability to manipulate reality as he was
able to transport desaad from one place
to another in an instant before too
firing that he controls all of reality
itself now we also see Yuga Khan
demonstrate an ability to manipulate the
source to some extent and he's able to
shut down all the technology on
apocalypse that derives his powers from
the source like mother boxes and boom
tubes and also cuts off every single new
god from the source as well effectively
neutralizing all their powers now use
akan is also able to produce incredibly
powerful energy blasts and was able to
single-handedly dismantle a fleet of
starships from New Genesis along with
them so yeah although we haven't seen a
lot of Yuga Khan in the comics recently
what we have seen is enough to let us
know that he is a force to be reckoned
with and probably one of the most
powerful and dangerous beings in the DC
Universe now I do want to point out here
this is the pre new 52 slash host crisis
version of you to can't but we have seen
the character pop up in the new 52
continuity as part of the Darkseid war
storyline now in Darkseid war Shazam
number one one of the one shots that
came as an aftermath to that story we
saw a new pantheon of gods that give
their power to Billy Batson one of these
gods is called zonas is I think that's
how you pronounce it which replaces Zeus
and the God represented in letters see
in the name Shazam which again is
basically an acronym for the first
letters of the characters that gives
Billy Batson his powers but zonas
explains that this is simply an alias
and that his true name is yuga Khan and
that he is the father of Darkseid Yuga
Khan steals the staff of the wizard that
straining Shazam and returns to
apocalypse to reclaim his throne
following Darkseid's death but is
defeated by Shazam himself and the
reason why this is important is because
this leads us to really the only bit of
information we have about the new 52
version of Yuka Khan which is that upon
defeating him Shazam is able to call
upon his power to manipulate the source
so we at least know that this version of
Yuga Khan possesses source manipulation
just like his pre new 52 counterpart did
now what this means for Billy Batson we
have no idea because we have only seen
him once we have no idea what Billy
Batson is doing right now we'll probably
find out in dark nights metal because
they all have to go to rock of eternity
which is where Shazam hangs out does
whatever it is Shazam is doing when he's
just hanging out probably playing
PlayStation he's not playing destiny too
because that game sucks but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys said
the
button to become part of the Rob poor if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]